so all over the country beginning early
last june school curricula have changed
completely and become explicitly
political and openly racist and most
parents have just sat there on their
hands
and watched it happen and watched their
kids hurt by it but one group of parents
in loudoun county virginia right outside
washington
is fighting back against all of this
against a curriculum that teaches their
kids to hate their country
and to judge their classmates based on
how they look on their skin color
several parents had the courage to say
this publicly a few days ago at a school
board meeting watch
crt is not an honest dialogue is a
tactic that was used by hitler and the
klu klux klan
on slavery very many years ago to dumb
down my ancestors
so we could not think for ourselves crt
is racist it is abusive
it discriminates against one's color let
me educate you
an honest dialogue does not impress oh
press an honest dialogue does not
implement hatred or injustice
it's to communicate with deceiving
without deceiving people
today we don't need your agreement we
want action in the backbone for what we
asked for today to ban
crt i had to come down here today to
tell you to your face that we are coming
together and we are
strong this will not be the last greet
and meet
respectfully
the first time we saw that video our
instant response was that woman her name
is chantel cooper
deserves an award she's a mother she's a
member of the group parents against
critical theory
and we're very pleased to have her on
the show tonight chantal cooper thank
you very much
for coming on what made you do this so
many parents have not done this
you stood up there and did this on
camera why
well it contradicts everything that
martin luther king fought for
it's hatred marx's ideology
and it places the child in a loophole of
oppression making them feel as a victim
i can't stand for that
amazing amazing so describe the
kinds of things that you're that you're
fighting against so the school is
teaching
children to judge one another on the
basis of of appearance
of skin color is that right
yes well it's our job as parents to
raise our children not the school board
one example i can give you was the
school was replacing
the morning announcement with news the
second
children reached out to find out how
they could help and join a club to see
if they could
you know relate with one another
undivided and they were denied by the
color of their skin for the equity
ambassador club
so certain kids couldn't get in i don't
even know what
colors you're talking about but but the
fact remains kids could not get into a
club because they were the wrong color
correct how is that different from
darker periods periods we consider evil
in american history
that sounds very similar
well plain example you cannot
further brotherhood of a man by
encouraging class hatred
our constitution is what unites us not
the color of our skin
yes so america it's just time for us to
stand up for one another
you know this this is the last free
country
wow what was the response i'd love to
hear you say that and i agree with that
100
what was the response when you did this
when you spoke
so publicly about what your school was
teaching
well it's been positive i never knew
that there were so many parents that
felt the way i did
i love people so for anyone to go
against
you know good but be be okay with evil
you can't fix a bad reaction with
another
bad action it just doesn't make sense
that's right that's exactly right
chantelle cooper i'm so glad that you
came on the show tonight
and what a voice you are i hope people
will emulate you thank you very much
thank you for having me
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else